[Music]
this year how did you celebrate your
anniversary did he do he didn't try
clouds again no
he's unique every year um he drove me
down to laguna beach um psyched me out
along the way like which way santa
barbara i'm like oh hon take this way
he's like nope you know so he did all
that the whole way down oh they're
tricking you what are we doing we don't
know where you're going and we just went
to a hotel but like this okay i'm sorry
can i just ask
what's the deal with dudes in hotels or
is it just my husband the second we're
there he's like let's go let's do let's
roll let's do this
i have my bag down he's like had this
whole like sex agenda oh oh oh he wants
to get right to it oh yeah well time is
precious at a hotel
i don't like every second couch oh
finally like a hotel
you're gonna lay down you have kids
right yes so well that's why you're in a
hotel i know just to get away from the
kids and get that over with and then
start watching tv get it over with
get it over with
you get it over with
the tv and the room service and the book
you want to read
i love these insights into you it's a
matter of getting poison out now he
wanted to get
it's that poison that makes babies yeah
so uh so so you had like this whole like
mental like log of like he wanted to do
it twice and he's like afraid if he
waits too long i'd all be too tired or
some [ __ ] and i won't do it so he's like
come on and i was like oh come what do
you mean is that his approach come on
yeah
come on
we got a schedule baby
two times let's go basically i was in
the bathtub the other night like i was
like
relaxed and ready and he's like roaming
you know pacing in and out sort of
checking the status of things you know
and um checking the status of your back
no i'm like you know are you done with
the bath because you're naked in a bath
you know what i mean like right he was
expecting something to happen when i got
out of the bath wow
this guy's just ready to go 24 7.
and that's so different from every other
man on the planet
[Music]
yeah
i'm not at 20. i'm not i mean i need a
little time you know
i'm 77 years old yeah i'm like
not 24 7 like 3 4.
uh-huh yeah he gets it once a week it's
not bad
this is incredible i've never
i don't think i've had this honest a
conversation with anybody in my life
and it's happening on television wow
my wife's never seen me naked and we're
having
i'm not we i'm dressed like this when we
you know get into mid i'm got the
microphone and the cup yeah
our next guest happens to be my wife
it's a true story